so now that you've seen apples
breakthrough face ID software I'm sure
some of you have some questions so let's
take a few yes will this work with a
photo of the face no no it will not it
requires an actual face so you need the
whole head your face yes
what if someone is sleeping your your
eyes need to be open as you look at the
phone yes
how about screaming you probably
shouldn't be screaming but it might
actually work I don't know does it work
with the butt no next do you remember
that movie faceoff with John Travolta
Nicolas Cage yes yes thank you okay now
stop right there if there are any other
real questions we'll take them what kind
of face mapping system does it use thank
you thank you okay we use something
called a true depth camera and this
analyzes over $30,000 question what's
the best way to remove the face what is
the maximum number of faces that the
phone can recognize that's a good
question it's just just one just you're
wrong I have six who are these people
are there any questions about using an
actual living face and your face thank
you very much I think we're done here
Siri can you please call the police
legitimate concern
you